it's interesting to see the level of
like savagery that these young kids are
doing right like they've been watching
the internet for so long oh yeah that
they have just learned to roast from
like the youngest age 100% 100% um so I
saw a clip of a 15-year-old destroying
chicks on a podcast similar to like
whatever fresan fit I think I know he
we're going to pull it up I thought it
was so funny I didn't know that I was
going to be sitting talking to a bunch
of illiterate people who don't know how
to read you're literally 15 what do you
know you know how to read yes I do know
how to read name 10 books are you
serious yes 100% name 10 books well I
read Game of Thrones I'm obsessed with
like the Twilight
series Game of Thrones the series what's
what's the book called It's not called
Game of Thrones she's just trying to
come up with a bunch of nonsense and she
can't name any actual books bro shut up
kid books you're changing the subject
actually three books three books okay
well the Game of Thrones
series it is a book it is a book but I
want the name of the book I'll Google
the book right now you want to show that
negate the point let me show let me show
you this Ser since you don't you don't
believe me I I'll show you since you
don't believe me the book is called The
Song of Ice and Fire now before you
embarrass yourself by looking up the
name of a book she couldn't even
actually name a single book she doesn't
know how to read she's clearly
illiterate like where do these kids come
from it is hilarious though it is so
funny is hilarious cuz she she is making
a bit of a TI of herself like I'm like I
think it would have gone over better if
she's like look I'm not a big read you
me be honest it's the fact that she's so
insistent and she can't believe the fact
that there is any possibility on this
Earth that he could one be right because
you know he's pointing out the fact that
her life choices means that she's just
basically an internet [__] she doesn't
want to accept that and also she doesn't
want to accept the fact that someone
who's younger than her could be smaller
than her let's look at the comments here
we have she's saying you're just 15 and
then pulls out the reading list of a
10-year-old girl yeah yeah oh no she
tried to bring him down for her ignorant
level and beat him with experience it
failed miserably her t-shirt told her
reality and background without even try
that's what made it even better is it
said por star on her
shirt do you think that selling your
nudes online and like do you think the
money that you make from that translates
to any sort of intelligence or skill or
do you accept the fact that you have no
skill and maybe lack a lot of
intelligence which is why you had to go
down that path that is not why I had to
go down that path I have a degree a
degree in what philosophy you could have
become a very well-respected lawyer had
a good career what do you think your
kids are going to think when they said
oh my mom had two options they could
have been a philosopher and a lawyer who
made a lot of money but they decided to
be an online home for 2 years and then
when they got ugly now nobody wants to
hire them anymore because they ruined
their name and their
reputation
you didn't even know what to say that's
the thing it's like I would have so much
more respect for these women if they
could at least acknowledge the the facts
of their choices yeah like if she could
just say like yeah like you know this is
the choice I made to me it was more
important to have money straight away
and I don't really care about working
and I don't have a good work ethic
that's why I'm not willing to go down
the path of becoming a lawyer I would go
wow Fair [__] play like you you you
live that life and you accept the facts
of it exactly but instead they want to
say there's no consequences problem but
that's what it just drives me mad it's
like the thing is it's always like you
know people will always come for people
like you and you know I'm only at 25k so
no doubt they'll come for me soon but
the the point is is that like they come
after people like us and they say oh you
you're you're judging and you're putting
yourself on a pedestal and all of this
and D it's like no no no no no no no
we're just asking to live in a world of
Truth yeah yeah cuz that's the most
important thing to me it's like what is
true what's true and they want to lie to
women so like they just they're
constantly putting lies on T and that's
actually not kind it's not that's not
kind to lie to people and to say that
it's okay to live in delusion and that
it's okay to to live in a lack of
accountability and and and lack of
regard for reality because ultimately
that only leads down a path of
Destruction so it's actually a lot
kinder to admit the truth of things even
if the truth makes you feel bad because
I'm sure her saying look I I don't have
the work ethic or the ability to strive
to be a lawyer I'm sure that would
probably make her feel a bit [__] about
herself but the truth is she then
protects other people from having to go
down that route cuz people can then
think about it well and then you can
kind of adapt accordingly like if you're
important I don't expect any guy to take
care of you the rest of your life if it
if it happens it happens great
but the odds are not in your favor you
probably will not be happily married so
develop a plan and act accordingly I I
saw a video the other day of like a
92-year-old
um ex like um hooker okay it was so
weird to see this old lady like talk
about all the [__] right she used to do
it so
funny um and it was sort of like the way
she was talking was so different than
how the younger women talk yeah because
she sort of was just like yeah I was a
[__] there wasn't no am I was I know
she's like yep did what I did there were
consequences that is it and this is what
Dutch van says he says that's exactly
right it's all good when we are young
and have the goods but when you are no
longer wanted as a nude you will have to
return to real life but your nudes are
out there still what employer will hire
you what man will date you a man doesn't
want all of his friends looking at his
girlfriend's nudes and the other issue
that I think we get you do get women
that it works out for I'm going to give
you a couple examples so that NBA player
that went viral for his wife starting an
only fans she's an NBA wife right Kim
Kardashian was a famous rapper wife and
how many times on the show do [__]
bring up Kim C all the time and they see
it work out for them and they they look
at the acception but they don't look at
the rues and even the exception it still
doesn't work out for them long term
because longterm they still end up by
themselves because they're too damaged
to stay in the relationship Kim
Kardashian will die alone now I is she
really going to be miserable as a
billionaire me I don't know that's
specul you have worse problems yeah
exactly but but my point is that is not
what is going to happen to the average
chick no the average chick will
literally die alone yeah which is why
it's it's not kind to not take
accountability for the circumstances of
your life because then other people will
see that and think that they can do the
same and then it's just a cycle that
repeats well and think about the average
only fans model makes less than $500 a
month the average only fans model makes
less than the average McDonald's
employee no
way wow I never even thought of that so
I think it's in the states that that
statistic is from I think it's in the
states the average only fans model makes
uh less than $15 an hour and I think
that's about the average the average
wage for a McDonald's employee wow but
it's that idea of it's not actually
about money they always use this cope
that oh I needed money or they they'll
make up some reason why they were in
these positions that all that was the
last thing they could resort to and it's
like no no no no no you're missing out
the part where you say you don't want to
work the issue is you don't want to have
to go and work an 8 hour shift well I
think that women would do it for free I
think they would do it for attention
women do look at their Instagrams yeah
yeah and this is the but they look at
Kim Kardashian and Kim Kardashian got
money Fame she got all of this stuff she
got high net worth individuals wanting
to marry her and it's like for every one
Kim Kardashian there is there's what a
thousand women that it doesn't work out
for or even um what what's her face like
call her daddy do you know who that is
Alex Cooper she basically put her sex
life on the internet and she's getting
married but she's oh yeah like she
there's no sex tapes or anything but she
had like a podcast and that's the
problem she got 50 million for it okay
maybe that was a good tradeoff debatable
debatable but you could you could at
least see the argument but most chicks
do that for free so they said if they're
upset about it they can cry in one of
their four Ferraris none of these
[__] are good do any of them look
like they have any business say you
think they know how to add like okay how
Petty of everyone in the comments
section to shame a woman they don't know
personally I mean why the hell do we
have to judge someone for their personal
choices when we ourselves don't like to
be judge she made her choice and she has
every right to as a human being having
morals is one thing but expecting the
other person to have lived the way
you're living is just a petty way to
establish you are superior in every way
one thing that I don't like shame comes
from within MH I it it's so interesting
when you see interviews where one
person's trying to shame the other yes
and they're just like yeah so nobody can
make you feel shame no you it comes from
within so you can't blame other people
for the way that you feel exactly only
you control how you feel and it's like
when you know women get asked about
their body count and then they they get
all like funny about it and then they
say oh like I'm not ashamed it's like
well clearly you are and also no one is
is saying that by having things like
shame and the concept of Tolerance and
all these different things no one is
saying that that's about establ
establishing any kind of dominance over
anyone to say that you are superior in
one way or another it's just having a
universal code of truth that means we
all adhere to a code of Truth where we
can all acknowledge what we've done in
our lives it is true no one likes to
feel shame but like you say the first
point is you only feel shame if you
decide to feel shame and if it if it
bothers you you will feel shame and the
second point to be made is that no one
is saying that this woman in this video
has to have lived how the 15-year-old
boy is saying or even like the way that
we are saying cuz we we would say yeah
you probably should have gone down the
lawyer route and no one is saying that
what we're saying is correct we are just
saying that if you are going to go down
a path you have to own it that's it and
it's the fact that every opportunity
they get they try and cope out of it he
says you could have been this why didn't
you and instead of her just being honest
and saying I didn't because of this this
and this and this is my choice and I'm
proud of it and you know you can you can
respect that at least she knows where
she's at it's the fact that she goes
straight to but I am I am intelligent I
have a degree and it's like she
obviously feels shame in herself if she
feels the need to have to say she is
something I've noticed this pattern in
so many people who come on the show they
constantly feel the need to tell the
room what they are I'm this I'm that
like you know I'm I'm a good person how
how often do we hear that you know I'm
intelligent I've got a degree how often
do we hear that you know and and also
another one I hear all the time is uh
like oh I I'm just real about things or
um wow I never thought about and it's
like if someone has to tell you what
they are chances are they're not the
smartest people I know never say that
they're smart you know they never like I
think of my I I think of the smartest
people I know are like literally my dad
and my brother Adam and even Austin's
really like my brothers really and I've
never heard them say that they're smart
because when you ask when you tell a
smart person that they're smart or like
say you're so smart they kind of are
like oh whatever because they know
people smarter than them yes you know
yeah yeah yeah and it's like the person
in the room who constantly feels the
need to say what they are is saying that
because it's a projection of the fact
that they're not so they project it
outwards and they say this is what I am
because they're inside like this is just
psychoanalysis whether they're conscious
of this or not is a different issue but
the the truth is at least from what I've
seen it's they can't feel it in
themselves so they feel a need to have
to say it cuz at least that way if they
convin if they can convince other people
of it that validates what they're
missing yeah cuz the people that always
say this is one I've noticed I'm so
real they're never real no they're never
real or or um I I I'm a what is it it's
always something like or I'm a I'm a
traditional woman they never look
traditional because traditional women I
mean they're rare anyways but it's like
the one trait they have is
humility and they're always thinking
well I could be better you know and
that's the thing it's like people that
are actually skilled in something need
to say that they are no and typically
they know people that are better than
them because that's who they're around
like the most traditional women are
around the most traditional women the
smartest men are around the smartest men
so they're always reminded yeah that
they are not the smartest person well
it's like if you if you have a job that
say the example that comes to mind is
for example a surgeon do you think a
surgeon walks into the room and feels
the need to tell everyone that he saves
lives absolutely not because every day
people thank him for saving their lives
whereas you have something else I don't
know say just like a a mundane normal
job a normal person job if that person
really feels unfulfilled in their job I
can guarantee you that they go around
telling people that you know I I I save
lives in this job or I do this or they
find some way to make out that what they
do is so important ultimately the only
reason they do that is because it's not
fulfilling them in the way that it needs
to when people are fulfilled they don't
feel the need to spread to the rest of
the world what they have because they
already had it have it why do you need
to project what you have if you already
are that or yeah or like people that
brag about money are the same way they
have so many people come on the show and
they say like you know like I'm quite
well off or I do this or or like you
know I get this I get that they realize
that we can Google their companies I
know like